la pandémie de coronavirus a poussé de
nombreuses personnes dans la précarité
ce qui peinait déjà à joindre les deux
bouts se retrouvent parfois dans des
conditions catastrophiques les personnes
sans domicile fixe ne sont toujours en
mesure de suivre les consignes
sanitaires ou de respecter le
confinement mais à moscou et saint
pétersbourg il peut désormais se faire
vacciner gratuitement contre le corona
virus selon différentes estimations la
russie compte de 1,3 million de sdf
les chiffres pour moscou varie de 10 à
60 milles pour saint pétersbourg de 50 à
60 milles le fardeau des associations
qui s'occupent des plus démunis c'était
nettement alourdie d afrique pendant le
confinement
bien évidemment le nombre de personnes
dans le besoin a augmenté et celui des
sans abri a peut-être aussi augmenté
même si à l'heure actuelle on ne le sait
pas avec certitude
on attend puisque la migration de main
d'oeuvre a sensiblement diminué ces
tendances se sont mutuellement
neutralisés mais moi c'est notre
impression à notre licha
bien sûr les données statistiques pour
le confirmer seront disponibles plus
tard
l'intensité de nos programmes dits
humanitaires dans le cadre desquelles
nous distribuons de l'aide humanitaire
de la nourriture et offrant un
hébergement de nuit notamment pendant la
saison froide a fortement augmenté le
nombre de personnes qui viennent
chercher un repas chaud dans le cadre de
notre programme autobus de nuit a
augmenté de manière assez significative
et a presque doublé
les températures de moins 20 degrés les
précipitations anormale ne facilite pas
la tâche
aujourd'hui les associations des deux
sans papiers avaient organisé la
vaccination contre la grippe en automne
maintenant vient le tour de
l'immunisation contre le coronavirus à
moscou une assistance complète et
fournit aux sdf en période de
restriction antico vide depuis mars 2020
le centre d'adaptation sociale glinka à
densifier son travail au cours de la
période de pandémie
en espagne les mesures sanitaires et de
prévention sont jusqu'à
respecter les personnes bénéficiant d'un
accueil de jour dans notre centre a fait
peuvent se faire vacciner contre le coc
u19 dans les établissements médicaux
joie ils sont accompagnés par un
travailleur social monaghan jeune fille
c'est une chose qu'il faut que je gagne
rhoda peace je suis très reconnaissante
au centre d'adaptation sociale et glinka
dont le personnel nous accompagne de
manière organisée non seulement pour les
vaccinations
mais aussi dans d'autres situations de
notre vie nous chaos ou ogoni j'ai pris
la décision de me faire vacciner et j'en
suis reconnaissante au personnel du
centre d'art où la courbe des
contaminations continue sa descente
partout dans le pays tandis que la
vaccination de masse bat son plein au
milieu de la campagne contre le corps en
un virus il convient de ne pas oublier
ce qu'on oublie trop souvent